MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Maker Group, where are you?
Maker?
Bueller?
Nobody?
OK.
Easy Ad, are you guys here?
You guys haven't submitted
your link.
Oh, you're not--
nevermind, because you
don't have one.
Keeping me on my toes.
We're missing the Maker
Group, I think.
They're in the back corner.
Can you go make sure?
Social Change, are
you guys here?
Charge, excuse me.
Do you guys have a--
You got G+?
You guys have to submit
the link.
I don't think you guys
submitted it.
MALE SPEAKER: Is there a way
to change this to an easy
shortened link?
Or [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: I'd just cut
and paste this URL.
I'll help you with that.
Do you have the link?
Should we get started?
Can you help these
guys get set up?
All right.
If you can hear me, clap once.
If you can hear me,
clap twice.
clap three times.
All right.
I'm loud.
So this works well.
Thanks guys for coming.
This was a lot of fun.
This is the most important
part, I feel like.
In a second, the judges are
going to introduce themselves.
Do you guys have a mic yet?
Yes.
So keep in mind, this is where
the value is for this night--
hearing their feedback,
critiquing your pitches.
You guys already met everyone,
so that's a good takeaway.
We only have one mic.
We should have more
than one mic.
Because that would
be awesomer.
You guys do like to talk, huh?
I'm on it.
Does that work?
So why don't you guys go ahead
and introduce yourselves?
CHRIS MESSINA: Hello.
My name is Chris Messina.
I am a designer on the Google+
UX platform team.
I started out at Google in
developer relations.
So I worked on our platform
stuff, and now I'm doing
design stuff.
So I vaguely, in the most
abstract way helped out with
some of the new Google+
design stuff.
So hopefully you guys have
checked that out.
And before Google, I was sort
of on my own doing my own
consulting stuff.
And now I'm fully employed.
DON DODGE: Come on, Chris.
You're being too modest.
Chris Messina is the inventor
of the hashtag.
This is true.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS DIBONA: I prefer to call
that the IRC channel.
But we'll talk later.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Hi,
Stacy Brown-Philpot.
I am the COO at TaskRabbit, a
little startup that helps
people get things done.
And I spent a number of years
at Google before TaskRabbit,
most recently as an EIR
at Google Ventures.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Hi.
I'm Stephanie Palmeri.
I'm a principal at
SoftTech VC.
We're a micro VC fund.
We actually co-invest with
Google Ventures quite a bit.
And we invest in B
to B and B to C
internet and mobile companies.
DON DODGE: I'm Don Dodge.
I work in Google Developer
Relations.
Yeah, Google.
I also work with Google Ventures
in my spare time.
Before that, I was at Microsoft
for many years.
And before that, I did
five startups.
Some of them you'll
probably know--
Napster, the music company, Alta
Vista, the search engine,
Groove Networks with Ray Ozzie,
and a couple others
that you probably don't
know about.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thank you, Don.
Four claps for Don.
So my name's Chris DiBona.
I look after open source
for Google.
And what you probably don't
know about me is I failed
multiple times in startups.
Succeeded twice, failed three
times, different times.
And yeah, I started Developer
Relations at Google back in
2005 when we launched
co.google.com
back in the old days.
I'm a limited partner at
Icon Venture Partners.
I'm also a Google Ventures
associate.
And I still work for Google,
running Open Source.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So just a quick recap.
You guys have two minutes
to present.
Ahmed over here is going
to be our lovely timer.
And then three minutes of
questions slash comments,
whatever these guys
want to say.
But we're going to try something
a little different.
And we're going to kind of take
it the big Omaha way,
where before everyone presents,
I want everyone to
get up, shout, clap, get really
loud, get them excited.
And that way, the pitches
will be a little better.
Get some energy flowing,
things like that.
So we're going to
give it a try.
I want everyone to stand
up right now.
Clap, shout.
The louder the better.
All right.
You can sit down now.
We'll call that a trial.
That was good.
All right.
So the order, because I know you
guys all have great eyes
and can see this.
We're going to go, I'm going
to read them off.
And then I'll let you
know who's going on.
But first, [? Scodio's ?]
going to be on.
They're in the gaming
vertical.
Smart Product Founder
is second.
That's health.
SATs with Friends,
that's education.
Take Time is the location
based gigantic group.
Apricot is fashion.
Cue Rates, enterprise.
Arc, media entertainment.
Glass MD is Google Glass.
Social Change is Maker.
That'll throw you off.
Sorry, Social Charger.
You're new.
I'm still learning your name.
Then Easy Ad for design.
So all your tabs are
listed up here.
You guys have nothing
to set up.
Just come over here,
switch tab.
If you want someone to Drive
while you're doing that.
That's good.
So you guys ready?
All right.
Let's give a big, warm welcome
to [? Scodio. ?]
Stand up!
MALE SPEAKER: You guys really
make the shirts?
MALE SPEAKER: Can we do
that one more time?
All right, all right.
So let's get started here.
Guys, we've been cheated.
I have really bad
news for you.
If you guys have played mobile
games in the past, really bad
news is the chances of
you playing a cheater
are really damn high.
Actually, around one in four.
This is not only a problem
for the user base.
But it's also a problem
for game developers.
Now, in real estate,
there's a saying.
And that is location,
location, location.
Well, in the gaming industry,
we have a saying.
That is retention, retention,
retention.
The problem that cheats are
bringing in to the table is
they're affecting a game's
ability to keep their
retention rates up.
And what happens next
is people will just
stop playing the games.
And then that affects a game's
ability to generate revenue.
Well, guess what?
We have a solution right now
to block cheats from ever
affecting a game's ability
to generate revenue.
Let me give you an example.
I'll just throw some
numbers out there.
You guys have, most of you
have played "Words with
Friends," right?
There are about 150 cheats
out there in the market.
You can just quickly go
in and type in "Words
with Friends" cheat.
And you can download the
cheats right now.
And in fact, the most popular
cheat for this game has about
between five and 10
million downloads.
That's just insane.
That means that every time you
play the game, one in four
times, you'll most likely be
playing against a cheater.
I don't know about you guys,
but that really sucks.
And it takes the fun
out of the game.
And it takes money out of
a developer's pocket.
So what we want to do again
is just bring a
solution to this problem.
It's a new, emerging problem.
But nonetheless,
it's a problem.
We like to think ourselves
as the next OpenFeint.
And we also like to think
ourselves as the next $10
million slam dunk.
Thank you.
Questions anyone?
Our panel?
CHRIS DIBONA: So as a
person who cheats--
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, don't
tell me that.
CHRIS DIBONA: So when you use a
trainer on a PC, and it sits
there and it watches the memory
space of the game, how
are you going to avoid that?
How are you going to fight
that kind of problem?
MALE SPEAKER: So there's
different ways
you can manage this.
Luckily for us, the mobile
space is quite
different from desktops.
And we have the ability
to be in a more--
in a sandbox ecosystem.
What that means is we have the
ability to detect cheats based
on a unique identifier, in
this case, for Android, a
package name.
And then we're able to have
a large definition list of
package names.
And that way, we know that we
for sure can detect that cheat
whenever it's installed.
And therefore, block it.
And let the developer know that
hey, this guy's cheating.
DON DODGE: So this
is a problem.
But who's going to pay you
money to solve it?
MALE SPEAKER: So what we're
trying to do is, we have SDKs
available for developers
to integrate with.
So it's as easy as three
lines of code.
And as soon as the developers
integrate with our service,
they can access all
the benefits of
anti-cheat for mobile.
Meaning they'll have the ability
to scan a user's
device against hundreds if
not thousands of cheats.
And that way, we'll be able to
provide the protection for
their games.
DON DODGE: So what does it do
when it discovers a cheat?
MALE SPEAKER: That's
a great question.
We don't want to do anything.
We basically want to let the
developer know through a
callback mechanism.
And then it's the developer's
choice to do
whatever they want.
They can nag them with a dialog
box, or they can just
simply say, you know what?
We're not going to let
you play until you
uninstall these cheats.
56 kilobytes, the JAR file.
It's extremely small.
I'm sorry?
We're basically targeting
apps.
Meaning, cheats that are
installed on a user's device.
I'll tell you what.
A browser is not going to do
what some of these cheats do,
which are extremely complex
and advanced.
Some of these cheats will
actually take a screenshot of
your ongoing game.
Use OCR, original character
recognition, to detect the
letters that are on the board.
And then provide to you every
single answer for that game
that you're playing.
It's insane.
And you're not going to get
that through a browser.
You need to have a native
application running, a native
cheat running in the
mobile device.
And that's what we're
blocking.
CHRIS MESSINA: So I got
a question for you.
Why didn't you go
the other way?
Like, why don't you provide
like an equalizer?
So if I'm playing against
someone who's cheating, I can
cheat, too.
You know what I mean?
MALE SPEAKER: That's a solution
to a problem.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT:
I don't play games.
So I'm struggling.
MALE SPEAKER: You got
to try "Words with
Friends." It's so fun.
It's so fun.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: But I've
always been taught that
cheaters never win.
But in this case, they do.
MALE SPEAKER: They
do, and it sucks.
Because what happens is--
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: How
do you market this?
You're not going to
make a decision.
So you're going to have the
developers make a decision.
So you can't market that the
cheaters will never win.
So what's the compelling
value proposition?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, you know
that cheats are bad for the
game, right?
We know that for a fact.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: Why are
they bad for the game?
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
a couple things.
What I mentioned, so it affects
the game's ability to
keep their user base,
the retention rate.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: And one
in four people cheat?
MALE SPEAKER: About.
And this is just, again, this
is just some numbers that
we've gotten from the market,
just looking at the number of
people that have downloaded
cheats.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So maybe
one or two of us here are
cheating right now.
MALE SPEAKER: Here's another
quick point I want to make.
CHRIS DIBONA: Do I have to
jailbreak my theoretical iOS
phone to do that?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, you don't
need jailbreak to cheat.
And that's also part of
the problem, right?
CHRIS DIBONA: Need it
to detect cheating.
MALE SPEAKER: No, you
don't need it.
You don't need it.
Absolutely not.
Just a quick note.
Another thing that they can
greatly benefit developers is
we also have the ability
to block ad blockers.
And if you guys are not familiar
with this, a lot of--
CHRIS DIBONA: Why would
anyone block an ad?
MALE SPEAKER: We have to
go to the next team.
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's give a big
standing ovation to Smart
Product Finder.
GEORGE: Hi, everybody.
My name is George Gabor.
And I'm here to talk about
Smart Product Finder.
So you go into a supermarket,
thousands of
products on the shelves.
Maybe you are concerned about
food allergies, glycemic index
if you have diabetes.
Maybe you're concerned
about calories.
But hey, do you have time
to check it all out?
Do you have time to read
all the labels?
Do you have time to look
at any of that?
Or are you just going to go, the
heck with it, I'm going to
get the product.
And I'm going home.
And maybe you're not getting
the best product that you
would want for yourself.
So that's a real problem.
How many of us are overweight?
How many of us are getting
food or other kinds of
products in our life that really
aren't good for us.
And we're not able to really
make the best decisions
because we don't have the time
or the energy to go through
all the data.
Well, Smart Product Finder
uses Google Glass to get
around that problem
and solve it.
You go to the supermarket,
you look at the shelves.
You've already told it what
you're concerned about.
If you're a diabetic, you might
be concerned about a
food with a high
glycemic index.
Maybe you're concerned about
calorie content.
Maybe you're concerned,
hey, is this GMO?
What's the probability that this
food is GMO or non-GMO?
Organic, trans fats,
you name it.
So you're looking on the
supermarket shelves.
And Glass is going to tell
you, a green light, a red
light, a happy face, an index,
how good does this product
meet your needs?
Or is this no, stay
away from that.
Or, you like this product and
this product, maybe you're
going to like that
one, or that one.
And there's going to be ad
revenue from that, right?
So also, it's going to tell you
like Amazon or other kinds
of services, ratings from
individuals and users.
You can say hey, this product
really worked
for me or it didn't.
And it goes beyond just food.
What if you're concerned
about a toy?
You're looking at a toy on a
shelf and Google Glass says,
wait a minute.
You're concerned about lead.
Your kid might take that lead in
that product and put it in
their mouth.
Or wait a minute, there's 500
people who said, this kid
bought this toy, my kid bought
this toy, and they got better
grades in school,
and so forth.
So this does potentially--
I think it's a killer app.
Because what it does
potentially, just as Netflix
changed the quality of what
people used for the quality of
what they have in their life
of what they watch, this
changes the quality of what
you have and what you buy,
what you take into your life.
And it does it so easily
just by Glass
giving you that feedback.
We out of time?
CHRIS DIBONA: So I'm a
large boned person.
Maybe I like living in denial.
Why would I go and spend
whatever Glass ends up costing
for the consumer, and then an
app I guess that I would buy
on Glass to do this?
GEORGE: You're going
to save time.
You're going to save a lot of
time based on what you want
out of life.
And with this thing telling
you what you like in life,
what matters to you when you're
looking at products,
especially food, whatever
you're concerned about.
Is it saving time in getting
what you want, getting that
instant feedback worth
something to you?
STEPHANIE PALMERI: How do you
think about keeping it less
overwhelming?
I'm walking down the aisle in
the grocery store, and there's
thousands of products that are
kind of jumping out at me now
with Glass, right?
So how do I walk through that?
What would I say in order
to make that--
GEORGE: Well, maybe
you're telling it,
maybe you're just--
OK, good question.
And maybe you tell it how much
data you really want.
Maybe it's not going to give
you anything until you hold
the bar code up to it and it
scans and gets the entry from
the databases, all the data
that's relevant to you.
CHRIS MESSINA: So if I
make Doritos, how do
I cheat this system?
GEORGE: You're a manufacturer.
We come to you for
certification.
And you can say, I want to
certify with my paperwork that
this is an organic product,
and it's non-GMO.
And I'm lying through my teeth
in the paperwork I fill out.
So that's how you can cheat,
although you might
get caught for it.
People may catch you
on it eventually.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: What
if you don't go
to the grocery store?
What if you buy everything
online?
GEORGE: If you buy everything
online, this
product is not for you.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So I can
eat all the ice cream I want?
GEORGE: Yeah.
Although I mean, I don't know.
Maybe there could be an online
app that attaches to your
computer that is related to
it that doesn't use Glass.
But maybe it runs in the
background and gives you that
extra information that accesses
the database as well.
So this could be an alternative
to the Glass.
You don't really need Glass
if you're online, do you?
DON DODGE: That's true.
What does GMO mean?
GEORGE: Genetically
modified organism.
And see, that's the problem.
Because right now, we don't
know, most people don't know.
And that was what Prop 37 was
about in this state earlier,
whether a product is GMO or
not, unless a manufacturer
tells you and certifies
it's not.
Or in the case of our app, what
it's going to do is it's
going to look at the
ingredients, and it's going to
give a probability.
Like if you're getting as a
soda pop and it's got corn
syrup in it, the probability,
if the manufacturer doesn't
tell you, it's going to be about
90% that the corn syrup
in that soda pop is GMO.
So it's going to tell you.
And unless they certify the
product in the database that
it's non-GMO, it's going
to warn you.
CHRIS DIBONA: So how
do you get paid?
And have you considered using a
temperature sensor to see if
I'm in front of the
ice cream counter?
GEORGE: That's a good idea.
I think there's some ad revenue
that's going to come
in from, if you like Product X
or Y, check out Product Z. Or
let's say that there's a GMO
Cheerios type product and you
say, oh, I want that,
but it's GMO.
And it's going to say, hey,
there's another product here
that's non-GMO.
And if there's three of them
available, there could be a
revenue stream by which
one pops up
as the first alternate.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much.
MALE SPEAKER: OK guys, can you
guys please keep it down?
[INAUDIBLE]
All right, who's next?
MALE SPEAKER: Let's give
a big, warm welcome
to SATs with Friends.
Hold on, hold on.
I got to pause.
Because I saw half of the
back room not jump up.
So let's try that
one more time.
I'm serious.
Everyone get up.
Let's get some energy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
So our idea is SATs
with Friends.
The problem--
studies have shown that
continuous exposure to
multiple sources of information
at one time causes
your brain to not have enough
time to store into short term
memory into long term memory.
And this is a problem that
children face today within a
technology driven environment,
especially those that are
studying for an intense
test like the SATs.
MALE SPEAKER: Currently, there
are 20 million high school
students in the United States.
Two million are test preppers.
This is a $2.5 billion
a year industry.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Our solution is
to create a fun mobile game
where they can play against
their friends or matched
opponent based on their
skill level.
And the engaging and repetitive
nature of gaming
would encourage competition and
memorization of the material.
And unlike a typical static
game, this game would be
social and real time.
And it would use advanced
matching algorithms.
So we're using Zynga's way of
keeping their users engaged by
matching them with players
of similar ability.
So that way the individuals
continue bettering their
scores and beat out
their opponents.
MALE SPEAKER: So what does
this game look like?
There are two categories,
math and verbal.
For the math section, you would
get three math problems
commonly found on the SAT.
You work on the problems and
then compare your results with
your opponent.
For the verbal section, you
would match definitions with
commonly found SAT words.
And points would be earned
based off of speed and
accuracy to ward off cheating.
The platforms we're looking at
are Android, iPhone, and
Google Hangout.
And our pricing format would
be have a free app and then
$3.99 for a pro version.
And also expanding to other
tests like the GRE and MCAT,
those types of tests.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So
who's your customer?
Is it the teacher?
Is it the parents?
Is it the students?
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's definitely
the students.
So the students are the ones
that are having to
prepare for this test.
Oh, sorry.
It would definitely
be the students.
Because these are the
kids that are
preparing for this test.
And usually, it's the parents
that are buying the test
preparation.
And so these kids are
on the app store.
They're buying apps, downloading
things every day.
So they would find this game and
be excited to play it and
play their friends.
So it's definitely
for the kids.
DON DODGE: Is it free
to download?
How's that work?
FEMALE SPEAKER: So it's
free to download for a
very limited version.
And you could pay more to get a
pro version to get more data
sets or more in depth
training.
So it'll go deeper if
you pay for that.
CHRIS DIBONA: So while I only
got 200 on the SATs, it was my
understanding there's three
sections now, isn't there?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, there's
also a writing section.
I think you would have to
probably figure out a way to
get essay prompts in there.
But I think that's further
down the line.
I think for now, it's a very
simple app where you're just
learning very quick memorization
skills on
formulas and things like that.
DON DODGE: Is it timed
for your response?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes,
it is timed.
DON DODGE: And you get more
points if you answer faster?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Correct.
Yep.
DON DODGE: Great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's based
on accuracy and timing.
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean, did you
guys also consider stuff
that's a little less like the
SAT in order to sort of
motivate to people to one, sort
of think about this as
being fun, and two, to get
people to come back to it
organically?
Maybe people who are not
studying for the SATs?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
definitely.
I think this lends well to a
very vast, wide range of
activities.
So it doesn't have
to be test prep.
But I think the goal of it is
to really encourage kids to
have fun when they're studying,
and to be engaged
when they're trying to
study and focus.
CHRIS MESSINA: Would you
be licensing the brand?
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I used
to work at Zynga.
But I mean, potentially--
CHRIS MESSINA: Full
disclosure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You could
definitely license this brand
out, for sure.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Take time to stand up and
cheer for Take Time.
BRANDY LEE CAMACHO: Well,
we got a lot of support.
Good evening.
My name is Brandy Lee Camacho.
Let me take this time to present
to you a team that is
going to announce our new
application, Take Time.
Currently, there are 1.3
million plumbers,
electricians, and AC
professionals in the United
States of America.
Many of them still use
paper to track
their time, work orders.
Current market leader service
CEO uses closed system and
does not integrate well
with a calendar.
There is a problem, a real world
problem, in the service
based industry.
Generally, service techs are
more effective performing
their daily job duties, not
performing paperwork.
Issues that are often found are
inaccurate timekeeping,
which results in a loss of
profits for small and medium
sized businesses.
Currently, service techs perform
a manual process that
uses paper to fill out
their work orders.
This results in errors.
The end result is a major loss
of profits for the business.
With current technologies,
there is a solution.
There is no reason to do
this manually anymore.
Take a moment to imagine your
service technician.
You have an Android
tablet device.
Your application will utilize
geofencing API to determine
time of stay at the work site.
Also, you will have the ability
to provide a voice
dictation of the work that was
performed, and calculate a
route between sites.
Small and medium sized
businesses do not have the
time or resources to tackle a
manual time management system.
By leveraging Google
technologies, we are providing
an accurate and an effective
invoices system which will
boost the overall profits
for small businesses.
Thank you very much.
Take Time.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: How do you
guys think about distribution
to the service professionals?
How do you actually get the
tablet [? enhancements ?] to
professionals?
And how do you actually get--
I mean, there are thousands
and thousands of service
professionals.
So you're not going to large
corporations and going top
down, so you're kind of going
to individual reps.
So how do you spread the word?
How do you market this thing?
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks to Google,
we have to market this
in the Google Apps for
Businesses, so we can
leverage this up.
That's of course one way.
The other way around would be
using AdWords to promote to an
online customer, which
is the first target.
Obviously, not all small
business will use our app
first day, but that's a start.
MALE SPEAKER: A lot of times,
for small businesses, they get
a lot of tips from
their friends.
And so word of mouth really
helps if you've got a great
application.
BRANDY LEE CAMACHO: Let's not
forget that these service
technicians right now already
have a smartphone.
I would have to say 90% of the
professionals out there that
are doing day to day services
are managing their business
solely off their smartphone.
Now, when they start using our
application, I'm willing to
bet they're going to migrate to
a tablet so they could be
more efficient on the site.
CHRIS DIBONA: So you don't know
this, but I'm a plumber.
And I have four trucks
running around Tampa,
Florida right now.
So the flexibility that paper
gives my guys is really pretty
significant.
I have bigger problems
like inventory
management and all the rest.
So what do you actually
selling?
Is this an app?
Are you selling a whole thing
that ties into my current
service software?
I mean, what are you
selling exactly?
BRANDY LEE CAMACHO: Well at
first, I would imagine that
this application would
be aimed towards the
individual at first.
So we could promote it and
get the word out there.
So this application will run
solely as a client application
on a device.
Then, we'll go ahead and start
introducing new service that's
going to be aimed towards
small businesses,
[? by request ?] individuals,
which is going to go ahead and
utilize App Engine
as the back end.
Store data, form reports.
Not to mention that when you sit
there and store your data,
as a small business owner,
you're going to be able to do
reporting, export that data,
import it directly into your
accounting system, such as
FreshBooks, QuickBooks.
And go ahead and have those
invoices automatically
developed for you.
Now, it does save time.
I understand that you're using
paper on your sites.
But let's not forget, your
service technicians are doing
this job manually.
Most likely, you're going
to be doing errors.
Maybe they want from Site A to
Site B and forgot about what
they did last 15 minutes.
You take 15 minutes with one
employee, you're billing out
$100 an hour.
That's $25 that you just lost.
Take that over the course of
week, you've got $125.
Over a month, it just adds
up, $500 per employee.
This program's going to
literally save your business
money and gain profits.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: How do you
deal with customization?
You broadly talked about
service providers.
And at TaskRabbit,
we work with a
lot of service providers.
And the skilled workers
are different.
People who clean houses, people
who are plumbers,
electricians, they
want customized.
And that gets expensive.
So how do you build a
scalable product?
BRANDY LEE CAMACHO: Well,
Google+ handles a lot
of stuff for us.
We're going to integrate Google+
within our product.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's give a
sweet intro to Apricot.
CHRIS DIBONA: Is that Apricot
with two p's?
I'm just checking.
Because we have a little Bingo
card going, and misspelling
things intentionally is one
of the Bingo things.
[INAUDIBLE].
Are you the fashion people?
Do you really think that
Christopher Moore is fashion?
No, go on, sorry.
I've really been more partial
to Alexander McQueen.
So just the latest shoe line
is fantastic, the three
buckled boot?
It's impossible to get.
But go ahead.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
All right, so we're
Team Apricot.
And our product is
vote your runway.
So here's the problem.
So if you're a student,
finishing fashion school.
You're trying to launch
your line.
But you have no money.
You're trying to get exposure.
You're trying to get people
to buy your product.
But there's no way to really
connect with new consumers, or
actually get money to
launch a product.
So here's our solution.
In a nutshell, it's like Project
Runway but online.
So what we're proposing to do
is have a monthly contest
where designers can upload
a project of the month.
And people can vote
on the project and
select their best product.
And the winner wins seed money
for their first fashion line.
So let's say for example,
this month is sweaters.
So each designer makes
their first sweater.
People can design it.
And then that winner will win
money for their fashion line.
So in the back end, how this
works is they're going to use
Google Apps Engine to run the
back end of the solution, and
to run analytics.
And additionally, people vote on
their products they want by
using pictures.
But if they want additional
interaction with the designer
or the process, we'll also
integrate YouTube for
inter-engagement
on that aspect.
So how do we make
money with this?
Number one is with
advertising.
So we plan on advertising with
key products in the fashion
industry as a way to
generate revenue.
Number two, it's actually more
of a crowdsourcing model.
So the top winner, in addition
to winning seed money from us,
is actually going to win money
from the crowdsourcing people
who vote them up.
And our take is about 2% to 3%
out of that in order to bring
revenue to our company.
And that's it.
Thank you.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: So
I look at a lot of
companies in this space.
A lot.
Can you give me a little bit
more of an idea about where
the funding is coming from?
I assume you're crowdsourcing
the voting.
But are people also pre-paying
for the orders?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes, they're
pre-paying for the orders.
And it's basically 50%.
So that's the incentive
for the customers to
order online early.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: OK.
And so then that prepay for the
order gets you enough to
do, like, volume
of order-wise?
Or are you selling after
the fact, as well?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Because it gives the designer an
incentive to say, should I
actually produce this from
a massive perspective?
Because you don't want to
produce something and no one's
going to buy it.
So it's a very good
indicator of what
consumers actually want.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: So one piece
of feedback on this,
just because I look at tons of
companies in this space, you
might want to think about the
fact that typically, these
designers actually create
a whole lineup.
And it's not just one
particular piece.
And it becomes very difficult to
sell one individual piece.
So thinking about how you can
actually fund a whole line is
something that I would just
use as food for thought.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
seed money is to
fund their first line.
It's the monthly competition
of that one item.
So customers can come
to the site, I'm
looking for a sweater.
And find the best sweater
out of all designers.
And then that money will
seed the designs, if
you like that designer.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Got it.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: How do
you deal with delayed
gratification?
I want my sweater now.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Yeah, on
Amazon Prime I can get it
like, tomorrow.
MALE SPEAKER: I can
take that one.
I think for sweaters that are
readily available on the
market, you do have a
legitimate question.
But right now, what we're
offering is this unique item
that nobody has, come up from
these fresh designers that
nobody knows about.
So it's worth the wait.
CHRIS MESSINA: So I have backed
probably five or six
fashion projects
on Kickstarter.
I won clothes for life
on one of them.
I don't know how that happens
but, you know.
I have probably gotten one
pair of boxers so far.
So I'm not wearing them
now, to be clear.
I am wearing some underwear,
but anyways.
CHRIS DIBONA: Do you anticipate
[INAUDIBLE]
like sandpaper?
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean,
I'm just saying.
Like, if I hadn't gotten that
pair of boxers, I may--
anyways, I'm not going
to go there anymore.
But I think this problem of
delayed gratification and
waiting months and months to get
fulfilment I think is an
interesting problem,
unless you have
some alternative process.
CHRIS DIBONA: You could
run out of underpants.
CHRIS MESSINA: That's
my point, right?
I mean, maybe there
needs to be a--
CHRIS DIBONA: You must
plan for underpants.
Sorry.
CHRIS MESSINA: That's the
crux of my question.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's
two things.
So we talked about A, how do
we guarantee that A, the
designers are actually going to
fulfill the promise, and do
what they're going to do?
So we actually had a
staged approach.
In which, yeah, you
won $10,000.
But you actually get
it in increments.
So our idea is if you win,
you have to upload
pictures and videos.
So like most successful
Kickstarters,
they give you progress.
And so you're sort of--
CHRIS MESSINA: So what you're
saying is like, I'm not
necessarily buying
the clothes.
I'm buying the process.
And then maybe, I'll get some
boxers or sweaters at the end.
MALE SPEAKER: Well again, the
seed money is for their
fashion line.
So you get the product, plus
you're investing into their
fashion line that they're
building.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And no designer
wants his or her
reputation ruined.
That's your reputation.
You're not just [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS MESSINA: I would
have thought that on
Kickstarter, too, but.
DON DODGE: Seems like this would
be a good application
for the big guys that are
putting out fashion.
Because they are constantly
guessing who is going to buy
this, and how much big
production runs to do.
So these are established
designers
and established retailers.
They have no clue what the
demand is going to be.
So maybe you could
apply it just to
that rather than designers.
But I don't know.
What do you think?
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Five star ovation for
[? Curate. ?]
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Imagine this.
You go to a Starbucks.
And the cashier there will
either be somewhat nice to
you, or will give you somewhat
of an attitude.
It's not worth it that you go
into the trouble of finding an
email or entering their lengthy
feedback forms.
But because the current state of
feedback looks like either
this manual or you have to enter
a URL or a scanner QR
code that will lead you to a
page that looks somewhat like
this, a 20 question survey.
But it doesn't have
to be this way.
What we're suggesting is a
very quick way to gather
customer feedback, either by
NFC or scanning QR codes,
where it will take you directly
to a very simple form
that looks like this, just a
smiley face and a slider.
And you can show how satisfied
or how dissatisfied of the
service you are.
And the data goes directly
to our cloud platform.
And we can give them near real
time or even real time
feedback of how their
service is doing.
For example, they can get five
unsatisfied customers and know
there's something wrong
in the branch.
And they can take an action
at the same time.
So what we are suggesting is a
way to solve and have people
actually give feedback.
And do all sort of things with
the feedback that we're
getting once we get it.
That's our idea.
Thank you for listening.
Do you have any questions?
CHRIS DIBONA: Have you
considered calling it Feedback
with Friends?
MALE SPEAKER: Friends
will always give
you positive feedback.
CHRIS DIBONA: They're
very unreliable.
CHRIS MESSINA: So why would you
do this from the company
side and not sort of on the
individual side, where
individuals are able to have
an app, or to talk about, I
mean, I am an avid user
of things like
Foursquare, for example.
And I make my opinions
known there.
MALE SPEAKER: As opposed to--
because the companies or
enterprises already invest a
lot of money in ways that they
want to gather their own
customers' feedback.
And they spend all these
reward points.
And it doesn't work.
Because it's not
done properly.
So what we're suggesting is
something that will actually
work for them.
CHRIS MESSINA: So you're saying
it doesn't work because
it's too complex?
MALE SPEAKER: Too complex,
yeah, the interface--
CHRIS MESSINA: But I'm wondering
like, is a smiley
face a sufficient way
of actually knowing
what's going wrong?
MALE SPEAKER: No, that's why
it's the only required thing.
All the rest can be optional.
CHRIS DIBONA: We're more worried
about frowny faces.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The difference
that this product is private.
When you complain
in Foursquare,
everybody can see that.
And this is only for the
companies that want to really
have their feedback.
But doesn't want to have
the complaints online.
This is to take the complaints,
and then change
the service.
If you have an immediate--
for example, in a hotel.
When you are in a hotel,
you want to
complain about the service.
And you want to complain now.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yes, like that.
If you don't have to wait to
have these complaints--
you don't have to wait
to [? attain ?]
these complaints until the
customer leaves your place,
you can change [INAUDIBLE]
right now.
And if you have another kind
of [? retailing scene, ?]
for example, a cafe, you
can see your customer.
You can now immediately
taste the coffee.
Say, yeah, OK, we need to
change the formula.
DON DODGE: So businesses
actually do have a big
problem with Yelp.
They want something that the
customer can complain
privately to them.
So if there was an app where you
could complain privately
and stop these negative things
on Yelp, then they
actually like that.
And they'd pay a lot
of money for that.
MALE SPEAKER: Correct.
Sometimes I want to report a
negative experience, not
because I want to defame
the business.
On the contrary, because I want
the owner of the business
to know about the attitude of
his employee and improve it.
And of course, customer
satisfaction
is not solved properly.
Because it needs to be
authentic, or it needs to be
very accurate.
DON DODGE: The other pain point
with Yelp is that the
businesses can't respond in a
timely fashion, or sometimes
even at all without extortion.
MALE SPEAKER: And there
is no way to tell--
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
thank you so much.
Let's give a jumping
ovation to Arke.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So while Tony sets up our
Google+, we did want to make a
mention that we had a sixth
teammate tonight, Dustin.
He unfortunately had to
catch a bus home.
Just wanted to give him
credit as well.
And then we're going to have
a little bit of audience
interaction in the beginning.
So we could ask for your support
and interact with us
with some of our questions,
we'd love it.
Thank you.
So how many people out there
have any number, amount, of
contacts in your books right
now that have more than one
phone number or one email,
raise your hands.
OK, great.
And how many of you have run
into a situation where you get
a mass email or you see a
Facebook group saying, oh, I
lost my contacts, can
I have yours?
OK, great.
And keep your hands raised if
you didn't post your number
because you didn't want
anyone else to see it.
So this is the problem
today, is contact
information is very static.
There's a lot of services out
there that crawl other social
platforms, that try to
aggregate this data.
But the problem really lies in
the fact that that data's
never posted, or people don't
put them in those places for
everyone to see.
And so with Arke, we have
our beta right now
on the Android market.
You can go down there and
download, A-R-K-E. And the
experience is very simple
to get started.
When you download the
app, you sign in
with your Google account.
It pulls your basic information,
and you add the
extra that you'd like-- work,
physical address and such.
Then as you initiate handshakes
on our network and
they're accepted, that's
when the magic starts.
That's when you can decide who
has what information at what
time and how they
can contact you.
And it's very powerful when you
think of people changing
phone numbers, changing physical
addresses, changing
countries even.
And being able to send out a
message to six different
platforms letting people
know about that.
And then all the problems that
ensue of people writing it
down wrong, not putting
it in, and losing
track of those people.
So we have a consumer
model for revenue.
We have a business
to consumer.
But one that's really
exciting is our
business to business one.
Imagine for marketing not only
to your clients but then to
also any loyal members
that you have, of an
always up to date CRM.
And what that can bring to
businesses of always being
able to follow their consumers,
or even follow
other businesses as they move
around, as they expand, as
they change that information
that again, isn't always
communicated and isn't
always posted.
And Arke is looking
to solve that.
Thank you.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: I like that
you guys are wearing Glass on
top of your head.
It's very stylish.
I'll probably do
the same thing.
So I work with a lot of really
early stage companies, and B
to C, B to B to C, B to C to
B. Where do you start?
You've got to pick one.
So where do you start first?
And then how do you move
to the next market?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, it's
a great question.
So we would start at the
consumer level, having normal,
everyone in the room, every
day people being able to
download that app and stay in
touch with family, with
friends, with college
roommates, all
of those user groups.
I mean literally, our target
markets are anyone who uses a
phone to call.
And so we have a very wide range
of who we can adopt and
who can market to.
And then eventually as that
model becomes successful, it
only makes sense to then enter
the B to C. So then business
users can keep track of those
customers that are already
successful and on the network.
And then eventually move to
that business to business
model in different areas such
as IT and also CRM.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: So if
you're starting with B to C,
how do you deal with privacy?
If a handshake happens and then
I want to un-handshake
from people, what do I do?
How do I easily-- if I
have 2,000 people--
MALE SPEAKER: That's
a great question.
So with Arke, there is row level
permissions as well as
group permissions, to instantly
add someone to
something that maybe only shares
your work email if
they're in a work group.
Whereas family get all
the information.
And the great part about Arke
is just the power that it
brings to people.
You now own your information
again.
So when you disconnect with
someone, they don't have a way
to contact you.
CHRIS MESSINA: So you're saying
people on both ends
need to use Arke?
MALE SPEAKER: They do, yes.
CHRIS DIBONA: It's Plaxo.
It's just a [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS MESSINA: I know, yeah.
Part of it too is like, you're
competing with a lot of
people, including Google, which
is completely fine.
But if you look at your profile,
you're able to
provide that information and
choose exactly who can see it.
And they'll be able to access
that information.
And we actually merge the
information that you already
have with that person
in the profile.
So how would you do something
different or better than what
we're already doing?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So first and foremost, a lot
of systems out there are
either platform specific or
they, like I mentioned
earlier, only crawl sights.
CHRIS MESSINA: You're
platform specific.
MALE SPEAKER: So with our
platform model of starting
with everyone on Arke, we
eventually move into the
ability for anyone to join.
And it's also a matter of, with
all these services out
there that already do it like
Google, people don't think of
Google as that place to go and
put their information to sync.
People think of Google,
first comes
search, then comes Gmail.
And so by starting with a
feature that everyone else has
added 10 years down the road, we
feel we can build a better
ecosystem with that foundation
rather than adding it on later
as an extra service, that people
don't think of and that
even in Google's case,
people don't trust.
CHRIS MESSINA: Ouch.
I won't take it personally.
It's all right.
But I guess we'll
work on that.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, let's
give a [INAUDIBLE] ovation to
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: How's
it going, guys?
I'm going to open this
up with a quick--
oh, that's right.
Yeah, good call.
With a quick switch of
the tabs on the web
browser over here.
So I'm going to open this up
with a quick little story.
My wife and I, we are
blessed right now.
We are pregnant.
And we go--
MALE SPEAKER: Actually,
she's pregnant.
For the record.
MALE SPEAKER: Believe it or
not, I'm eating for two.
We go there, and the OB/GYN has
no idea who we are, how
many times we've been there,
and what we're there for.
It was incredible.
And I could not think of a
better situation for Google
Glass, where the purpose is to
get information into the hands
that need it when
they need it.
By implementing technology as
simple as a card with a photo
on it and EMR information,
electronic medical
information, like patient's
first name, DOB, height,
weight, et cetera,
these doctors can
make decisions faster.
So for example, 93%
of doctors use
electronic medical software.
70% say that it reduces
clinical errors.
Medical IT spending
is at $69 billion,
according to our records.
And it's improving, it's
increasing, at 9.7% a year.
Not to mention, just imagine
what this could do for
physicians' NPS scores.
Hospitals are going to be our
target market, followed by
large medical groups.
We would be implementing
a per seat per year
charge for the service.
I'm going to close this with
another personal story.
My dad right now has
prostate cancer.
And honestly, if there's
anything that I can do to
improve his patient experience,
I will do this.
So an investment in us tonight
is an investment in the health
care of your family.
DON DODGE: Have you ever tried
to sell anything to hospitals?
MALE SPEAKER: Though I have
not, we have industry
contacts that do.
DON DODGE: OK.
It's very, very difficult, and
takes a long, long time.
You'll be an old man.
MALE SPEAKER: This would be
something that would piggyback
on top of an existing technology
that would already
be out there, such as Athena
Health's cloud product.
CHRIS DIBONA: So my name's
David [? Tortiana. ?]
I run Partner Health Care's
surgical wing.
So am I going to be
able to wear these
inside the OR suite?
Is that the idea?
MALE SPEAKER: So our target,
we're thinking just
pediatricians, initially.
So you go into your GP or
whatever, and they would have
it right there in the
office visit.
MALE SPEAKER: It also includes
additional features such as
the geofencing, where you could
set it up on a per room
by per room basis.
And when the physician, when a
doc enters that room, it can
actually trigger an event that
loads that person's data.
CHRIS MESSINA: What type of
hardware certification would
Glass have to meet in
order to be used in
this kind of context?
MALE SPEAKER: That's going
to be a tough question.
All the medical records and
making sure that it's
privately protected.
I don't think the
current API--
we'll probably have to go to
the GTK which they just
announced today.
So that you could directly talk
to the medical system, as
opposed to storing it
on Google servers.
So that would be an issue
we'd have to resolve.
CHRIS DIBONA: Have you put
your Glass through an
autoclave yet?
MALE SPEAKER: I have not.
But I saw it go through a
blender in the hacking class.
And it actually didn't
fare so well.
But I got to imagine it was a
cosmetic [? dilemma ?] anyway.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: I think
this is interesting if you
actually have more information
beyond what that specific
physician knows about you.
So if you're going to the
pediatrician, and you know
something about the parents.
Or if you're going to the
OB/GYN, and you know something
from the pediatrician.
The cross information of data is
more interesting than just
the specific information
to me.
MALE SPEAKER: Some of these
companies also have CRM
software that could be
integrated as well.
And you could have literally a
ticker that's scrolling with
the most relevant information.
CHRIS MESSINA: So Google tried
a health product a
little while ago.
And I'm wondering if things have
changed enough now where,
if instead of worrying about
the physicians having these
types of tools, that if
individuals have access to the
stuff, have a way of storing
this information, have a way
of, let's say, using Glass to
actually pull up their medical
information, that maybe a better
approach, a simpler
approach, a faster to market
approach, would actually be to
sort of revisit that, an
individual storing or
collecting their own
information.
What do you think about that?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, that's
a total switch, I think.
Total 100%.
I mean, I think there's
a lot of
applications in health care.
And that could be one.
I think the one that we're
on could be an
interesting one, as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
Let's give a friendly ovation
to Social Charge.
FEMALE SPEAKER: First of
all, thank you for
saying the name right.
Social Charge.
Don't you just hate it when your
devices run out of power
when you're on the go?
CHRIS DIBONA: Oh, I hate that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I know.
So do I. Forget your charger?
Too many chargers to
carry in your bag.
This is a problem that
we are all facing.
CHRIS DIBONA: I hate that!
FEMALE SPEAKER: So Social
Charger, we provide you the
solution through this 24/7
convenient, reliable, and
established solution.
What we offer, we offer a
product with a sphere-like
stylish product that
could power charge
most of your device.
We would partner with partners
like [INAUDIBLE]
taxi drivers, Peet's Coffee,
an airport location,
convenient locations for
you to charge your
devices on the go.
We want to provide a social
app where you can get
notifications when your device
are low on power.
You see through Google Maps
where are the convenient
Social Charger locations are
to guide you to the nearest
salvation point.
Now the market is huge.
By 2020, there are 10 billion
connected devices.
Only counting 1% of the devices
charging five minutes
per month, we're looking
at a $1 billion market.
Of course, the pie is huge.
But we're looking at starting
at a small place.
Well, our huge San
Francisco place.
And we want to scale and expand
through partners with
[INAUDIBLE]
like natural synergy
companies.
And you may ask, how
do we make money?
We make money two ways.
Number one, through advertising
with AdSense.
And number two, through charging
per minute charge
with Google Wallet.
Thank you.
CHRIS DIBONA: So I think your
battery starved model is the
same woman as the barista
in that last pitch?
No, no.
So is the idea to distribute
batteries to all these
drivers, or what's
your goal here?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Taxi drivers.
CHRIS DIBONA: Charged
batteries?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Airport.
So we'll provide many
charge stations.
CHRIS DIBONA: So you're going to
have Nexus cues everywhere.
CHRIS MESSINA: We've got to
do something with them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: 2 plus
1 Google point.
CHRIS MESSINA: So
wait a second.
Whenever I order an Uber, or a
Lift, or whatever, or SideCar,
or what are the other ones?
Like Slice and Taxi.
I don't know Taxi.
I'll have to download that.
Anyways, I'm like, hey dude,
do you mind if I plug in to
your power thing in the front?
And he does it for free.
So isn't your competition
free?
FEMALE SPEAKER: One device, your
smart device, was iPhone,
he'd probably have
that charger.
Lucky for you.
However, I'm carrying my iPad,
my Lenovo laptop, Ultra OU1,
all this kind of--
CHRIS MESSINA: Your Blueberry,
and your Blackberry, and your
Windows Phone.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I do not--
my purse is not that big.
I need to be stylish.
CHRIS DIBONA: Are you saying
Androids aren't stylish?
MALE SPEAKER: This also allows
a way for them to make a
little bit more money.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's a revenue
share through with our
partner, with taxi drivers.
CHRIS MESSINA: I'm just going
to give them my phone.
This is going to cost
way too much money
for me to live anymore.
I'm kidding.
I'm not giving them my phone.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're looking
at prototyping, targeting
maybe around $20 per device.
So we're looking at starting
with San Francisco, starting
was 2,000 device to start
with, partner with.
That's probably $100,000
on that, $2 million.
That would get us started.
DON DODGE: How much per minute
is it to charge?
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're looking
at the initial model, to be
work in progress, we're looking
at $0.25 per minute.
DON DODGE: And how long does
it take to charge a phone?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Assuming power
charging, that we can
[INAUDIBLE]
some super magnetic product,
then we're looking at five
minutes charging time.
DON DODGE: Five minutes.
So this charges super fast.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
our goal.
MALE SPEAKER: We're thinking
of leveraging the super
charged thing you can
see at airports.
And we're also thinking of
possibly doing some sort of
advertising model where you can
look at an advertisement
instead of--
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: What's
the ad model?
I don't get that.
I mean, is 3D images going
to come out of the--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Potentially.
We can partner with
Google to do that.
Our thinking is, when you're
charging your device for five
minutes, you're really
linked to the device.
And then through that time, your
captured audience, and
with that 3D projection,
you can really
change people's mind.
CHRIS DIBONA: So since we're
being fabulous, I'm Elon Musk.
Could I trade in my Tesla
for a charged Tesla?
FEMALE SPEAKER: That would
be a great idea.
DON DODGE: No, this actually is
a big problem, to be able
to supercharge your phone super
fast, that's a big deal.
I'd pay for that.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: How big
is this going to be?
Is this going to be a thing I
could put in my purse and run
off with when I get
out of the Uber.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is probably
not fitting the
prototype, but we
would partner--
place it at a Peet's or airport
or taxi, they will
provide plenty of space.
But probably not
personal purse.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Is it big?
Is it--
I can't tell from the picture.
Is it life sized there?
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
thank you so much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, last
but not least, Easy Ad.
Go for it.
CHRIS DIBONA: Is this Easy
Ad with two d's or one d?
MALE SPEAKER: One d.
CHRIS DIBONA: Is it
E-Z or E-A-S-Y?
Yes?
Not helpful.
Because our Bingo card says, if
they don't have vowels or
do short spellings, we
get extra points.
Is it Easy Ad, does
it end in .ly?
Ad.ly?
Is that an i or a bracket
at the end there?
CHRIS MESSINA: It's good.
OK, let's go
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
We want to have a quick
question and quick
conversation with you guys.
So how many of you guys have
made apps, or are thinking of
making one?
Awesome.
So the problem is that
most mobile app
startups have great ideas.
But they have a hard time
finding the right advertisers
and don't know how to integrate
ads into their app
for a great user experience
that's not intrusive.
And this is a design problem--
so something that might pop up
or something that's flashing,
the banner, what have you.
So the solution is Easy Ad.
We are a service that connects
app makers to advertisers.
App developers can finally
concentrate on making an app
instead of figuring out
how to monetize it.
MALE SPEAKER: Easy Ad has
two main components--
the client that is installed
with the app developer's app,
and our back end service that
returns ad content based on
demographic and location
information.
The app developer does
not need to know
anything about the ad.
The workflow is, the app
developer gets demographic and
location information from their
Facebook login or their
proprietary own login and the
device's geographic location.
That information is sent to our
Google cloud, which has
our services running on it.
Easy Ad dynamically gets the
advertiser content based on
the user's demographics
and location and
returns the ad content.
Our Easy Ad app component,
that's a library with their
app, displays an ad overlay,
that's very subtle, seamlessly
over the application, using
one of our many templates.
For example, the
semi-transparent ad overlay
walks a company and product
name over the
bottom of the screen.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So our target
audience is anyone who has
created an app or wants
to create an app.
There's over 900,000
active apps on iOS.
And from iO, there's 900,000
Android apps.
CHRIS DIBONA: So what would you
say the opportunity would
be for advertising?
So I'm an app developer.
I like apps.
So how hard is it for me to
integrate this into my
application slash website?
MALE SPEAKER: So this is a
library that you would use
with your Android or
iOS application.
That you install it once
along with it.
And you don't have to
worry about it.
Once you install that library
while you're developing your
application, you just need to
link up, like we said, the
Facebook token or your own
proprietary token that you
send to us.
And we overlay that in
a very subtle way.
We want to be very subtle.
We don't want to be the
ads that we all
see, the pop-up ad.
This is subtle.
Your eye is not really going
to be super drawn to it.
But it's going to
be very subtle.
Because we concentrate
on design.
That's what we do.
So our product is, we outsource
that ad, the
connector to the actual
advertisers, as well as
creating really nice looking,
subtle ads for you.
So you can concentrate--
CHRIS MESSINA: So you're
basically an ad agency?
MALE SPEAKER: No.
We connect you with
the advertisers.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: Who do
you connect us with?
The advertisers or the app
developers or the--
I'm an app developer.
You're connecting me to who?
MALE SPEAKER: We would
work with Ford.
And so you have an app.
You're creating Seamless,
or whatever the app is.
So you would just send us the
demographic information,
demographic and location
information, location so we
can connect you to a
local business if
you want to do that.
And then we connect you with
Ford based on that
demographic.
Say OK, Ford wants to sell to
30 to 40 year olds in this
specific location.
We send the ad back.
STEPHANIE PALMERI: You're
now the target market.
CHRIS MESSINA: What kind of
rules are there about passing
this data on that you
get from Facebook?
Are you able to just sort of
like smear that data all over
the place, or what?
MALE SPEAKER: This is your
basic Facebook profile
information, just the
basic information.
CHRIS MESSINA: Right.
But I provided that information
to the app.
And so then the app hands that
off to you, the advertising
sort of go between.
And then you give that to--
MALE SPEAKER: We do.
But the good thing about this is
that this is the most basic
information.
How many times have you
installed an app, and it asks
for all these different
things?
Like I installed Sonar
last night.
I didn't even know if I
wanted to click OK.
Because it was like 80
different things
it wanted to get.
We're doing the most basic
one, basic information.
That's date of birth.
That's what country.
CHRIS MESSINA: I mean, that's
all PII, still, right?
MALE SPEAKER: But that's
a Facebook token.
That's what everybody's
Facebook token.
Whenever you click a
Facebook login or
sign up, that is sent.
STACY BROWN-PHILPOT: I think
there's a bigger opportunity
to actually serve ads that the
people want to see that are
using the app, instead of the
ad that Ford wants to serve.
MALE SPEAKER: Think about
this, though.
So we're trying to solve the
monetization problem for the
app designer.
If it's Seamless, and their
businesses is getting food
delivery to people, they don't
want to have to think about
advertising and all this
kind of stuff.
That's not their business.
But about the application isn't
really relevant, either.
It's really about who
you are, your
demographic, your location.
MALE SPEAKER: Here's the other
piece too, is that--
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
thank you so much.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
we finished.
Round of applause
for everyone.
Woo!
Thanks for standing up.
All right, so this is
going to be quick.
Judges, if you guys can follow
Ahmed to, I think we're going
to use that conference
room over there.
Decide of the last
hour, which five
minutes are your favorite.
We're going to stay here,
maybe do a few
interviews in the back.
So if we pull you aside, we've
got some questions for you.
Martin's also throwing up a
survey here if you guys have
some brutal advice or
input, comments,
whatever, for the event.
But yeah, stay tuned.
And we'll elect a winner.
So let's hang around.
INTERVIEWER: Welcome to Pitch
Night, gentlemen.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Glad to be here.
MALE SPEAKER: One more thing.
If you spoke into
this microphone
tonight, we filmed you.
I don't know if you knew that.
We also have a release if you
guys want to be shown in our
video, which we'll probably
put online afterwards.
So I think we're going to have
someone standing where?
Right here.
OK.
So if you spoke on this
microphone, come see us.
Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Welcome to
Pitch Night, everyone.
I'm here with [? Scodio. ?]
So guys, what was your
inspiration for
your product tonight?
MALE SPEAKER: I think our
inspiration came really from,
we all play games.
We love gaming in mobile
and PC and all this.
And just the fact that we were
playing games and being
constantly cheated, and losing
to people unfairly, it was
terrible for us.
I think that's what really
pushed us to really come up
with a solution for
those cheats.
And come up with an anti-cheat
system that
really works for mobile.
INTERVIEWER: Excellent.
So did you come to this
event with this idea?
Is this something you've
been working on?
MALE SPEAKER: We did.
It was actually something that,
again, we play a lot of
games online.
And just constantly getting
cheated over and over again,
we said, guys, we've got to
do something about this.
And really that's how
it came about.
INTERVIEWER: Awesome.
So how do you feel like the
pitch went tonight?
MALE SPEAKER: We thought
it went pretty good.
We were a little bit
nervous at first.
And slowly, got more calm.
And I think people understood
what the whole concept of our
product is.
INTERVIEWER: Excellent.
So do you think that the
feedback that the judges gave
helped shape your
product at all?
MALE SPEAKER: I think so.
I think the feedback was
objective, which is always
something we appreciate.
And also, it was from leaders
in the industry, and people
who have the experience.
So it's always great
to hear from them.
INTERVIEWER: Excellent.
Will, tell us just a little
bit about your product.
MALE SPEAKER: So what
[? Scodio ?]
is, is an anti-cheat solution
for mobile games.
We currently support both
iOS and Android.
And we have an SDK for
both platforms.
So developers can just go sign
in, download the SDK, and
really in a matter of five
minutes, they can go in and
integrate their games
with our solution.
And this way, they'll be able
to pretty much block every
single cheat out there, as long
as it's listed in our
cheat database.
INTERVIEWER: Excellent.
Well, thanks a lot, gentlemen.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for having us.
INTERVIEWER: Great.
INTERVIEWER: You'll find
out, won't you?
Great.
So you guys want to introduce
yourselves and what group
you're with today?
In the mic, so they can hear.
ALEX PALMER: I'm Alex Palmer.
And we're with the group
that did the Glass
project on Glass MD.
INTERVIEWER: Glass MD, OK.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm Sasha.
And I'm a developer based
out of New York.
And I'm the same thing,
Glass MD.
INTERVIEWER: Great.
Do you guys want to talk a
little bit about how you came
up with the idea, and how it was
developed over the night
or before the event?
ALEX PALMER: So we all split up,
and had separate projects.
And so the two of us were on a
separate project for most of
it until the end, when we voted
on the final projects
that would go on.
So I don't know very much about
the early development.
But we can talk a little
bit about what we
did to develop ours.
INTERVIEWER: Sure, go for it.
ALEX PALMER: So we were going
to do an app for like a
teleprompter.
So essentially, you've got
people, and they're looking
down at a teleprompter.
And when they look down, you've
got the problem of you
want to have good eye contact.
So it's nice because you
have good eye contact.
But some of the problems you
have are, you've got slides
that you want to have synced
up to your Glass.
So there are a couple of
things that you can do.
You can swipe.
And as you swipe, it will
change the slides in the
background.
But you might have too much
text for a specific slide.
So you need to think of
a way to solve that.
And so some of the things that
we talked about were a look
down feature, where when
you look down, it
starts to scroll down.
And then you look back level,
and it levels out and stops.
So you can read and scroll
at the same time.
INTERVIEWER: Was this one of
the pitches that just went?
ALEX PALMER: No.
Because we were on
separate teams.
Because we all split up into
I think four projects.
INTERVIEWER: What were
some of the other
ideas, just out of curiosity?
ALEX PALMER: So we had--
MALE SPEAKER: I think one idea
was the business on the go.
So like a live, real
time translation.
So what happens is, I think they
were trying to market it
to organizations who do business
as a multinational.
So you have various languages
involved.
So Glass would come in and do
the translation while you're
talking with someone in
another language.
Also, it would be a tool
that teaches you the
language over time.
So that was the other idea.
INTERVIEWER: So only
three ideas were
pitched for Google Glass?
ALEX PALMER: So we had
a travel idea.
I don't know if--
well, I don't know if
I can mention it.
But there is an Easter
egg in Glass.
And I don't know if I
can talk about it.
But essentially, we wanted
a tour app where
you could walk around.
And as you walk around, you
look at your Street View.
And so you've got Street View,
which is a 360 degree picture.
And as you look up, you see
the different landmarks.
And then they're also labeled.
So you can kind of see
the environment
as your inner person.
So you could do a tour from a
remote location, or you could
do a live one.
INTERVIEWER: All right great.
Thanks, guys.
Appreciate it.
MALE SPEAKER: Sit
down, sit down.
Come on, everybody.
Let's go.
Here's my 30 second pitch.
A lot of you guys
came from iO.
I don't know how many of you
know about Startup Weekend.
But our organization, our goal
is to spread and democratize
entrepreneurship through events
like Startup Weekend.
We're a nonprofit.
We have tons of events all
around the world, whether
you're from San Francisco,
Chicago, Asia, Europe.
You name it, we're there.
If you guys have any interest
attending our events and kind
of taking an idea like this,
developing it more and turning
it into some sort of business,
check us out.
StartupWeekend.org.
We love Google.
Why don't we give a round of
applause for Google for
hosting us here.
It's a fantastic place.
Martin, [INAUDIBLE], Stephanie,
thank you guys so
much for helping us.
And another round of applause
for our judges.
Appreciate you guys
coming out here.
DON DODGE: OK.
First of all, thank you
all for coming out
and doing this tonight.
It's late, and we appreciate
you all being here.
You did a terrific job.
One of my other jobs, I'm like
a professional judge.
So I just startup competitions
probably 10
to 15 times a year.
CHRIS DIBONA: He also
does DUI court.
DON DODGE: And I see over
500 pitches a year,
500 pitches of startups.
And some of you here tonight
were better than those guys
that spend their life
doing this.
So you guys really
did a nice job.
To tell you a little bit about
how we do this, we have
scoring sheets here.
And we scored each one from one
to five, five being the
best, over four different
categories.
I don't know if we told
you about that.
But anyway, we all put
our numbers down.
We calculated the results.
We went into the other room.
And we said OK, put your top
three companies on the board.
So all five of us put our top
And that's how we determined
the winner.
One company, only one company,
showed up on
all five of our tallies.
And that company is
SAT with Friends.
MALE SPEAKER: All right guys,
SAT with Friends, come on up.
We'll do a picture.
And you guys get some
cool stuff.
So you get to hear more
from our lovely
Don Dodge over here.
He's going to give you
a coaching session.
Credits for the Google Cloud
Platform, Google swag, who
doesn't like Google swag, and
a ticket of your choice to
either Startup Weekend
or Next, which
is the other program.
So let's get a picture.
You guys, thanks a lot
for coming out.
Make sure you clean
up your stuff.
Don't forget laptops, bags,
you know the drill.
So thanks.
Appreciate it.
And see you next time.